the Shriners at 2022 children's open is
in full swing a fixture of course on the
PGA tour schedule the tournament brings
in some really big names and Golf to TPC
Summerlin and they're all competing for
a really great cause Candace Charles
joining us live from TPC with really
who's taking charge on the field and
Candace the impact that this will have
for Shriners
good morning have a good morning folks
you guys just look out here it's a
beautiful view here at TPC Summerlin and
they've had a few changes to make it all
look as good as it does right on time
for the Shriners open which really is a
big event for the PGA Tour but also for
the youngsters that it impacts and I'm
joined by Brian Hawthorne the general
manager of TPC Summerlin tell us a
little bit about the changes that have
happened here you said there is slight
but you know what you had six months off
and you spent a lot of money on this
right yeah I hope you're not looking for
an argument we certainly did do that uh
you know it's been a wonderful
reinvestment in this property we've been
hosting this tournament for 31 years and
this past spring uh April 15th we closed
and have been working on a renovation
since then uh totally regressed the golf
course so every Fairway every Green has
been totally redone and our first
opening shot was this past Monday so
there's been a lot of excitement with
the the the work that's been down the
golf course and and we're showcasing it
this week awesome okay now I see I know
you've seen a few of the golfers already
who are you excited to see and who
should people be writing up those names
for for their bets yeah you know you're
putting me on a slippery slope here at
the risk of appearing biased but you
know we've got a lot of local tour
players that that live here and
certainly know this golf course very
well and there's a lot of excitement
with with those individuals uh you know
maybe a little inside scoop Taylor
Montgomery who grew up here uh and his
dad is one of my colleagues in in this
industry he's probably want to take a
look at for sure so uh but you know
again not biased there goes to school
from Brian we appreciate it really
quickly I know it's all about the
patience as well the youngsters tell us
what makes it so exciting for you guys
to have them back here yeah exactly that
you know we I've been part of this the
Shriners uh Organization for a number of
years and while we don't have a physical
property here there are an incredible
number of folks that get care from
Shriners and I personally have a number
of friends that have children that
receive care and you know to really
special to be able to give back to that
great charity and you know we're just
excited to be part of it awesome Brian
thank you so much and thank you for all
the work that you guys do it does look
beautiful out here I appreciate it and
it all kicks off today you can see some
of those youngsters at around 6 30 we'll
be showing you a little bit of a sneak
peek of it and of course there are still
tickets available so you can go ahead
and get your bed set up as well let's
help a great cause I have all those
details for you on 8newsnow.com for now
live from TPC Summerlin I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now and what a sunrise
behind Candace there that was absolutely
gorgeous okay well we can be a little
biased